let me ask uh perhaps a strange question
but uh
you know proponents of bitcoin will say
uh things like bitcoin fixes everything
so why do we need ethereum
uh versus like bitcoin
plus lightning network for scalability
uh and then using bitcoin for
with this proof of work for security so
in this kind of um
it is perhaps sort of a strange question
but it's a high-level question
why do we need another technology
yes there's a bunch of nice features but
like
doesn't bitcoin fix everything already
so
and the thing that always attracted me
about
bitcoin is you know these values of you
know decentralization creating these
open provisional systems that anyone can
participate in
and that aren't just going to flop over
and die if whoever created them gets
bored and like no
that are resistance to like whoever runs
them breaking the rules and all of these
things right and
i think that pretty strongly that these
principles are
like really valid in importance to much
more things than just money right like
bitcoin is
the blockchain for money and ethereum is
uh built from the star decision a
general purpose blockchain right it's
you know
there is ether the asset on ethereum but
then you can also make
you know decentralized financial things
what we call d5 today
um you know you can make like ens the
decentralized domain name system
um you can put make prediction markets
on it
you can uh make totally non-financial
systems that just like keep track of
whether or not
some certificate was signed or whether
or not some like cryptographic key got
revoked
there's this big long list of like just
interesting things that you could use
about blockchains to do
right like basically they are sort of
the missing piece that
um where without them the kinds of
things that a decentralized computer
network can do is very limited
and once you have them you know a lot of
those limitations end up going away
uh and so
ethereum was like always from the
beginning about that right it's about
like hey
this isn't just money this is there's so
much more that you could do
if you could just go ahead and make any
infrastructure
or you know digital institution or dao
or whatever you want to call it
where you the kind of the base layer of
the logic is just executed in this open
and transparent way where everyone can
see what's going on or you know if you
like your zero knowledge proofs at least
everyone can see proofs that prove to
you that
what's going on follows the rules um and
you don't need to
like just constantly keep trusting
centralized actors
and hence the smart contracts exactly
as being a sort of a core technology as
part of ethereum
yes exactly smart contracts the computer
programs that are running on ethereum
they are like the core of what makes
ethereum general purpose
yeah um so i think like i do think that
you know there's a lot more that wrong
with the world than just money right
like i'm not one of these people who
thinks that
you know if you get rid of fiat currency
and you replace it with cryptocurrency
then suddenly wars are gonna go away
right because
like first of all um you know like
senoraj revenue is only a small portion
of government revenue right it's like
what
five ten percent something like that
second of all like if
you are the sort of um this is one of
the things i don't even get about their
philosophy like
let's say you're the sort of person who
is a like an extreme
and very distrusting libertarian and you
think that these governments are
terrible
right like we we know today that
governments find a combination of uh
you know things like welfare and things
like you know the military that
you know goes and like bombs people in
afghanistan right and
the so the question you have to ask is
like okay you
um with your new um you know
magic newfangled cyber currency that
takes over the world
take away the government's ability to
have seniors revenue and so you reduce
the government's revenue by 10
if the government is that evil which
portion of its um
expenses is it going to take that 10
from is it going to stop the bombing
people in afghanistan or is it going to
cut welfare
if you think it's the first you have a
very optimistic view of the government
right so that's
i guess my perspective on like why the
whole um you know
we're going to save the world and create
and
uh create peace by like denying
governments the right to stealth
taxation kind of perspective doesn't
really make much sense for me
and i do think that there is real value
that comes from a
decentralized and open currency like
just the fact that there is a financial
infrastructure that anyone in the world
can
you know go ahead and use right like
it's uh
and that's something that can easily be
a big boon for people right there's a
lot of places
where the uh currency and
is much less stable than the dollar and
you know these people like they don't
like well if they use bitcoin
their only option is to get bitcoins
right which you know are also pretty
volatile
um if they use ethereum then you know
they can get ether but then they can
also get stable coins right
and you might think that you know oh
you're not being ideologically pure now
you're giving them stable coins which
are mirroring dollars and obviously
dollars are going to collapse too
but the reality is that delvers are
vastly more stable than the venezuelan
bolivar
so like there are
really like meaningful and beneficial
things that you can
give to people by cr having a global and
open financial system but i think
if he wants to actually do that like you
have to have much more than just a
currency right
and then if you want to go beyond
financial things then you know you have
to
obviously have much more than a currency
and then
you know you also have to actually
actually take scalability seriously
because
non-financial applications like nobody's
going to pay five dollars a transaction
for them
you